the member states nes nintendo wii the
commission must come out of its
ivory tower
the waves of expulsions are exploding this is the
case in spain this is also the case on
strike have been able to sea as we can hello to
all I have been looking for  everything increases
it's catastrophic if people do
n't have they will still have to go and
steal to attack people must
not stay in situations there is a
possibility that he will get up again
nikos winter nothing
two restaurants in the  heart and strasbourg
christophe raynaud the volunteers of the
restaurants of the heart of limits
nothing all levels of service
christopher and the night is business in
massif which is a homogeneous team in
europe
woman with many processions it's
still a hassle because as we
should say  that i find work
but if there is no sleep there is
no work are i go to sleep at
work voice is what i mean
this gir sleeping in the street like that that's that
is not like sleeping in a
real  i read we agree